Okay, it is time for hatriot mail. Hatriot
mail is when a professional voiceover artist,
interpretively reads the hate mail that I
get. A quick reminder about what Hatriot Mail
is now with a whole slate of new Corona virus
related hatriot mail introductions.
Last time I checked, this was America. And
I have the right to share my droplets with
whoever I want to read.
Written by patriots who hate David Pakman
because of America and because freedom.
That's a good one. That's a that's a very
good one. OK. Let's get right in to this week's
Hatriot Mail.
Why doesn't David marry Joe Biden if he loves
him so much? You are such a fearful little
child. Pacman dude's a corporate scourfield.
You had the lamest political show on YouTube.
I don't even follow your show. You just proved
David Pakman that you are relatively ignorant.
You're angry. Coller Jimmy is 100 percent
right. And I have no idea why I'm still subbed
to this tripe.
This is a playground thing. You know, if you
like Biden so much, you should marry him because
you're gay, right? I mean, these hatriot have
regressed. Or maybe they never progressed
past, sort of like being 10 years old. It's
weird. And unfortunately, many of them are.
I know this is crazy, but they're in positions
of power in this country. Come on, guys. We're
adults here, okay? Biden is good on some issues.
He's less good on other issues. He's orders
of magnitude better than Donald Trump overall.
We shouldn't DFI politicians. We shouldn't
idolize politicians. And by the way, nobody's
forcing you to subscribe to me. Yes, we are
on the path to a million YouTube subscribers.
That's true. But you don't have to be one
of them. Hopefully we'll get over the finish
line by Election Day. But if you want to bow
out, by all means, do what's best for you.
I am confident that there are very few of
these haters relative to the people that are
signing up. And I think we'll have some very,
very big things to announce. From the standpoint
of a million coming to you very soon. Remember
that you can use the coupon code hatriot 40
to get 40 percent off the membership of your
choice at join Pacman dot com. The spelling.
Very important. All lowercase. All one word
hkt r i o t four zero